looked at your credit score lately
reports have shown an unexpected boom in
fico credit scores but before you embark
on that next shopping spree or apply for
a loan just know that spike can be a bit
misleading
you should not get fooled by these high
credit scores dr ann kaplan mulholland
started a multi-million dollar company
called i financed 25 years ago it
specializes in loans for medical dental
and home improvement bills a credit
score is just one factor she uses to
determine whether or not to loan someone
money the
amount of
understanding we have to have of that
borrower
is astronomical that goes into i think
there's 62 variables that go into making
that one credit decision lenders are
looking at your bank account history and
stability as well if you move too often
or change your phone number that's a red
flag according to experian credit review
americans hit a record high score
throughout the pandemic landing an
average of 7-16 but kaplan mulholland
says the higher scores are misleading
because they're attributed to folks
spending less due to the lockdown people
are not shopping people are not
borrowing people are moving home with
their parents whatever you do don't
cancel a line of credit simply because
you're not using it having credit
history that is open and more of it to
use will give you a higher credit score
she says and in order to maintain it now
what you need to do is utilize that
credit so if you have a credit card or a
line of credit buy things with it but
pay it off before just before the
deadline date just before that deadline
date will show that you know how to use
credit and you pay it off
now if you're wondering why dr ann
kaplan mulholland may look familiar in
addition to starting her own
multi-million dollar company she also
stars in the housewives of toronto